Joachim Bühler Geschäftsführer des TÜV
Verbandes Herr Bühler der TÜV ist ja die
Sicherheit es geht um die Sicherheit der
kerntechnischen Anlagen in Deutschland
dafür sind sie zuständig und drei AKWs
die bleiben jetzt weiterhin am Netz
allerdings ohne neue Brennstäbe für die
AKWs zu kaufen wie lange sind diese
Brennstäbe denn überhaupt noch nutzbar
guten Morgen die drei Kernkraftwerke
haben noch so viel Brennelemente dass
ein streckbetrieb mindestens mal bis in
das Frühjahr hinaus möglich ist und das
betrifft jetzt auch das neue neu
hinzugekommene Kraftwerk Emsland rein
technisch gesprochen ist es im Grunde
genommen auf dem vergleichbaren
mindestens auf dem vergleichbaren Niveau
wie die zwei Kraftwerke im Süden und von
daher ist es aus technischer Sicht auch
folgerichtig auf dieses Kraftwerk mit
einzubeziehen wie schnell lässt sich
denn so ein Kraftwerk wieder hochfahren
wie schnell ist es wieder aktivierbar
und dann tatsächlich auch wieder full
power am Netz
kernkraftwerke sind grundsätzlich
ausgelegt um Grundlasten zu bedienen das
heißt es sind keine an- und abschaltbare
technische Anlagen die Nachttischlampe
sondern das sind Anlagen die eine
gewisse vorlagezeit brauchen und
deswegen war es auch so wichtig dass wir
jetzt eine Entscheidung haben geht es
mit dem Betrieb weiter oder nicht es
müssen zum Beispiel jetzt Vorbereitung
getroffen werden weil eigentlich sollten
Sie ja bis zum Ende des Jahres vom Netz
und wir müssen noch warten und müssen
auch Prüfung gemacht werden das braucht
Vorlaufzeiten und diese Vorlaufzeiten
brauchen wir jetzt dringend und bis zum
Ende des Jahres die Sicherheit dieser
Kraftwerke auch zu gewährleisten damit
sie bis zum Frühjahr laufen können
können Sie das noch ein bisschen
konkreter sagen wie lange genau braucht
man dafür was heißt Vorlaufzeit genau
wir hatten jetzt im Oktober die
Betreiber mir angegeben im Oktober diese
Entscheidung haben zu müssen um halt
alle Vorbereitungen treffen zu können
das eine ist die rein technisches
Anfahren Kraftwerk da gehen wir von
mindestens einer Woche aus eigentlich
zwei Wochen dann haben wir die
Wartungsarbeiten dafür braucht es
Personal dafür müssen diverse Firmen
zusammenkommen die ganz Vorbereitungen
müssen laufen und normalerweise fängt
man macht man einmal im Jahr eine
Revision bei einem Kernkraftwerks wieder
Auto TÜV eigentlich wenn du das
passierte mindestens einmal im Jahr und
man sagt nach der Revision ist vor der
Revision normalerweise braucht sie ein
Jahr Vorbereitungszeit jetzt sind wir
hier knapper dran aber diese zwei Monate
oder knapp zwei Monate die man jetzt
noch hat die werden dringend gebraucht
um einerseits das Personal zu besorgen
alle Beteiligten in die Kernkraftwerke
zu bekommen um die Prüfarbeiten zu
machen und Bewertung Wartungsarbeiten zu
machen und dann braucht es technisch
gesehen mindestens noch eine Woche nach
dem Herunterfahren um das Kernkraftwerk
wieder voll ans Netz zu nehmen Joachim
bühlert vielen Dank für das Gespräch an
diesem Morgen
[Musik]